welcome to this video playing probably
the number one from Antarctica yeah so
you can choose the Flexi ax Oh Raymond
Kaufman's and international master from
the US but ok he likes to have odd
arctica in them ok let's see the bull go
here Queenie 7sm one of the traditional
main lines of the bull go india it's
usually followed up with 96 here Jack
just actually a bit uncommon the smooth
order because it allows me to place the
knight on c3 uh-huh
not interesting maybe you can you can
play that the queen is a bit misplaced
to help recapture the poem and I cannot
play III here we said after having a
plate g3 and I'm not sure I want to take
no I don't want to take
but it's not clear at all how to how to
get the porn back maybe a quick night
you have that's the trick yeah I think
you should take now you bonus upon if
you don't take no it's not quite clear
what the idea of all this is of course
ok you can castle and I'm not sure I
want to play a move like b3 this looks a
bit strange so yeah now he takes it so
look see one probably yeah this is some
one point getting quickly am on the
default
very interesting opening player black
hmm 23 years got 94 just can write quite
annoying but what should I do
now Knight g4 I was thinking Queenie for
maybe
how curious
that he allows me to play 95 mm I was
surprised no I should have good chances
to get the porn back I think
Queen just Queen d2 jump 22 a son so
justice wrist tapping into the the
default what else maybe c5 was since I
was this idea
my queen is indeed not very well
positioned on the default like wynia 3
also looked a bit weird I thought that
now he doesn't have a great discovered
move with the night i hope i'm right now
right up I'm probably in decent shape
it's still this good bishop on g2
yeah keep it simple just take this
yeah this is now this is excellent now
queen is a good locator on d 4 eva and I
just have complete control now let's
play some quick moves
okay yeah keep it simple what doing
anything fancy here of course it's the
queen is not so bad on d4 but Lucas
better piling up on the porn yeah i can
take g for now I thought I was hoping
that he that this was a plan
black resign yeah early resins was also
down down one minute and his it's full
of weaknesses t5 he probably I was also
a bit annoyed at spoiling this position
I think black was was probably quite
good here in the opening I really didn't
know this idea oops wrong direction this
idea with d5 so it's quite interesting I
don't really want to take this this this
frees up his bishop okay this night is
not great on c6 but it's not a big idea
a big problem I don't want want to do
this because here this bonus is one
problem and d5 is an idea maybe not now
but in the near future and he also
doesn't need to take immediately on 10
so I played played this and after this
here it's it's quite interesting this
rock d 8 is coming quickly and it's
putting pressure may be naughty 5 was a
better first and here it's really a bit
a bit of a problem how to get this so
this bag this was very helpful for me I
think no I'm getting the porn back
here's something maybe the Queen before
very directly I'm not show it all but
this this now should be should be fine
again maybe even though the computer
wants to take on c5 this is not so
interesting okay
yeah it's giving this idea attending you
form hmm yeah interesting and this I
don't know here he needs to improve
somehow because also I didn't understand
why I didn't take here this looks better
I think done this this now is very one
sided with this week pawn on d5 yeah
okay this I'll i gladly take now I'm
interesting he probably spoiled it with
foam giving me see for back so easily at
least in terms of an advantage should it
wasn't terribly bad i mean to play how
he did but maybe he could have really
gotten something instead of this this
night before yeah thanks for watching